there you are who doesn't love dogs
golden retrievers
chocolate lab a german shepherd or a
yorkie pugs
jack russell
what else
and a boxer
oh we've got a lot of dogs
puppy place is about two kids lizzie and
charles who fall into the joys of
fostering dogs
they try to find dogs homes and have to
deal with different situations that come
with fostering dogs this truly is a
dream come true
no i'm serious i actually dreamed about
it i've been a dog person my whole life
dogs
everything else each book for us is
really a jumping off point i have 65
books with more coming so i was like
this is fantastic i promise
it's specifically about the children and
how they are learning life lessons
learning responsibility and the way they
do that is through their friendships and
through fostering and re-homing dogs
trust me we can handle it lizzy's very
smart and determined and she knows
everything and anything about dogs you
know more about dogs than most adults
i've worked with charles is a problem
solver he always tries to help the dogs
i'm putting him in the crate it'll help
him get comfortable in his new
environment tucking a man like we used
to do with you except jack's not asking
for a little more screen time
real funny dad they put everyone else's
needs before their own this is princess
our new foster puppy your son is my hero
we have a different dog every episode so
with these dogs lizzy and charles try to
find people who mostly match the dogs
and dogs that mostly match the people i
don't think we're a match
seems too elegant and i'm a man of the
people
what do you think i love about playing
lizzie the dogs i grew up with dogs dogs
are awesome just full of love dogs
comfort us we came to cheer you up
they're loyal they kind of do everything
we need for us without asking much in
return i'm ready for my lunch
one of the most rewarding parts of doing
the show is that the cast and crew get
to adopt the dogs and it's really cool
because sometimes when they adopt dogs
we get to see them again
totally local residents in nearby
business really hope dad's okay well you
could certainly use a hot shower
one of the biggest lessons is family
comes first and we all need each other
doing this felt good and i think when
people watch it they'll be able to feel
good watching it's also really cool to
be a part of a show that has such a
great message about rescuing dogs we did
it yes
we want people to think about animal
rescue animal fostering and if you like
dogs then it's a good show for you to
watch it's fun and it's organic and it
has honestly been the most fulfilling
experience of my life
that's i'll be placed in a nutshell
[Music]